so what about he 1523
what's exciting a red a red giant star
yes
uh that's another one of you babies yes
13.2 billion years old
uh yeah um so that one isn't quite as
iron deficient as the other one so
probably not a second generation star
but easily second third sorry third
fourth fifth or so we we can't really
pin it down but that's also not super
important for us what what is important
is that that star has a very different
chemical composition in a sense that yes
we have all the elements up to iron
there
they have sort of normal
ratios uh which means kind of the same
as most other old stars and not too
different from the Sun or at least you
know different in quantifiable ways
um but it has this huge overload of very
heavy elements
and what was so nice about that stuff in
particular was that I could measure the
thorium and the uranium abundance and
again that was the second of its kind
um but the uranium abundance was could
be more well determined so we had a
better grasp on that now why arthurium
and uranium interesting
um they are radioactive elements they
have they Decay thorium has a half-life
of 14 billion years I believe and
uranium of 4.7
which uh you know to focus on us on
Earth is a really long time but those
kind of timelines are really good when
you want to explore the early universe
so
there are two questions now that that
kind of come to mind
where do these elements come from and
what what do they tell us right and
um these as we know
these heavy elements are made in a
specific process it's a neutron capture
process usually referred to as the r
process for Rapid Neutron capture
process we talked about seed nuclei
before right so we still don't exactly
know where this process can occur so you
have let's say a lone iron atom
somewhere and it it is in an environment
where you have a strong Neutron flux
which means there must be lots of
neutrons around and again when we talk
about the side we can summarize and
Ponder where where that might be the
case
um but you have this iron atom and you
bombard it with neutrons and you do it
incredibly fast now what happens in the
process that iron atom you know you
collect lots of neutrons it becomes
really big and unstable so it's a heavy
Neutron Rich nucleus
that wants to Decay
because it's not stable it's way too big
um and so let's say you add only one
Neutron to it that would already make it
unstable so it will then it has a
characteristic Decay time that's called
the beta Decay time scale so it will
Decay to a stable nucleus so the neutron
will convert to a proton and that makes
it stable
if you know bombard lots and lots and
lots of neutrons onto that seed nucleus
within that time scale of the beta Decay
that's how you get to this huge fat
Neutron Rich nucleus that then wants to
Decay right so the r the rapid process
is you have your seed nuclear they get
bombarded you create these these really
heavy Neutron Rich nuclei
they are heavier than uranium even
the neutron flux stops and then all
these heavy nuclei they Decay and they
make all these stable isotopes that that
we know of all the way up to thorum and
uranium
so that rapid nuclei Decay is what
creates all the functions correct and
the whole thing is done within two
seconds
so just to add to the rapid here
and literally the snapping on my hand
it's it's all there in my talks I often
I have this nice simulation that that
illustrates
um you know this creation of these wrap
of these heavy neutral nuclei and I
always say this is the only simulation
you will ever see that's slower than
real time
because in astronomy you know we show oh
this is how Galaxy forms 13 billion
years in 30 seconds
really short right this is the opposite
me showing you this the element is
already long long made so where and when
does this happen does this process so
you need the strong Neutron flux
the clumping of the the neutrons yes
that's right and so there are not that
many options right so where do you find
lots of neutrons in the universe so it's
neutron stars right neutron stars form
in the making of supernovae of the
explosions
okay so maybe some of this heavy
material gets sort of made in the making
of the Supernova explosion and then gets
expelled
or you have neutron stars so the you
know if the neutron star survive I mean
usually that's the leftover of the
Supernova if you have two from a binary
pair so Stars usually actually show up
in pairs and so it's not too unusual to
um create a pair of of neutron stars
that will still orbit each other after
both of their progenitor stars have
exploded
and those two neutrons cells will orbit
each other diligently but as we know now
thanks to ligo the gravitational wave
Observatory
uh I mean we know already that
before but now it's been measured by
ligo is that these two neutron stars
they will orbit each other for like
forever but in the process they will
they will lose energy so that that orbit
is what we call the orbit decays and
eventually the two Neutron cells will
merge and that results in a in an
explosive event that has roughly the
energy of a supernova but uh the process
is completely different and the cool
thing is when these two neutron stars
collide they produce a gravitational
wave signature because neutron stars are
super dense objects they are like giant
atomic nucleuses so there's a lot of
interesting physics happening already
and so if you basically form a super
neutron star by Smashing two into each
other
uh more interesting physics happens and
that means that there's this Ripple sent
out you know into the space uh the you
know the space-time Continuum basically
you know the what do people say the the
ripples of space-time you know it's like
yes it's like you drop a rock into water
right you see the waves coming so that's
exactly what happens when two two
neutron stars emerge and this is
Neutron's Galore right it's really
violent to smash two neutron stars you
know so that are so dense already into
each other
and um they in in 2017 one of these
events occurred and the ligo and Virgo
gravitational wave observatories they
detected that and then the astronomers
pointed their telescopes in that
direction and they indeed observed what
we call the electromagnetic counterpart
so there was something seen in the sky
that faded over the course of two weeks
and that's light curve that light was
exactly
what you get when you create all these
heavy Neutron Rich nuclei in the r
process and then the neutron flux stops
and then it takes about two or three
weeks for most of them of these nuclear
2 DK2 stability so we saw the astronomer
saw in this electromagnetic counterpart
the nucleosynthesis of heavy elements
occurring
and that's that's just that's amazing
awesome so that's awesome that's
electromagnetic counterpart to the
gravitational waves that were detected
with yes two neutron stars colliding
aggressively violently to create a super
neutron star and that's where you get
all the neutrons the neutron flux
somehow and then that the whole shebang
that happens in two seconds and creates
a bunch of so that confirmed that one of
the sites for sure is for the r process
to occur as neutron star mergers
interestingly enough I have to mention
this here A year prior in 2016
my former grad student Alex G and I we
discovered a small dwarf Galaxy
that is currently orbiting the Milky Way
it's called reticulum 2 that was full of
ancient iron deficient stars that also
had a strong signature of these heavy
elements exactly like he1523
we weren't looking for that I actually
wanted to prove that they had really low
levels of heavy elements because that's
what we had seen in all the other dwarf
galaxies
and I was dead set on showing yet that
that is yet the case again and that that
is a typical signature of early star
formation we already talked about low
strontium and barium abundances and the
oldest Stars right this is what we had
seen anecdotally in in the ancient dwarf
galaxies that are surrounding us so
that's an ancient dwarf Galaxy the
network galaxy has a bunch of ancient
stars in it yes
and so now we find reticulum 2 and it
has these the Stars show the signature
of the rapid Neutron capture process the
r process and we elect
okay these stars are located in a dwarf
Galaxy right now we have environmental
information they are not lost in the
Galaxy where we don't know where they
actually came from now we know these
stars were formed in that Galaxy because
they're still in it
and that we already deduced from that
that it must have been a neutron star
merger that went off in reticulum 2 at
Early times that polluted the gas from
which all our little stars formed